I think self-awareness is really
important I mean I think it was know
thyself
Socrates right I think specific to my
experience in life being this pale kid
with white blond hair when the teacher
would turn around her eye or his I would
focus on me so I feel like I get my
victimization complex I feel like I was
blamed for things even if I wasn't
participating but that being said what
I've learned in the acting world is you
you you be you have your force to
embrace self-awareness we all have
moments of self-awareness and you know
maybe it's looking at a photo of how
good we looked five years ago versus
today like oh my gosh I didn't realize
there's but with actors they're forced
to face the reality of who they are and
how they come across so I played
football and wrestled in high school I
played football in college but I'm
mostly cast as nerdy people and so now
that's not to say a football player
can't be nudie and nerdy but but it's
like there's this I remember this
realization like why am I being cast as
this that's just how I come across and
you know I'll often meet people and
they'll say I thought you'd you're much
taller than I thought because I think
there is and it's fascinating and in a
narcissistic way that people think that
I'm shorter than I am but I think with
acting and being a character actor which
is code for not attractive in the
entertainment industry you're forced it
you know actors are forced to embrace
the eye
eeeh of auditioning for a certain type
so you embrace that so it's like the
schlubby friend okay I guess I'm a
little schlubby if I'm considered for
this role but with stand-up going
onstage this conversation that you have
with the audience where you have a
microphone and they communicate mostly
through laughter and silence you have to
become immediately aware of how you come
across and that that communication is I
think vital for particularly my type of
comedy so if if I didn't learn that when
I would go on stage and this comedy club
called pips in in Sheepshead Bay
Brooklyn if I didn't realize that I was
this white bread guy and everyone in the
audience was like Italian and Jewish and
they looked at me like John Tosh if I
didn't address that they would think I
didn't have a self-awareness so that
self-awareness
I think disarms the audience that you're
attempting to engage so like you it's
it's not undifferenced about the weather
when they say aura like so I think
self-awareness
is Willy it's it's a it's a great
icebreaker self-awareness particularly
on appearance and how you might come
across it disarms it gets rid of
barriers of communication so if you're
underdressed and you bring it up and
you're like I'm sorry I'm on you know I
did I'm sorry I'm overdressed for this
people can sit back and go alright this
guy does no he's not dressed properly
and it's it's bringing some equality to
the to the relationship you have with
someone